[Music]
with worldwide box-office takings of 1.1
to 8 billion US dollars Captain Marvel
was one of the top performers
financially in the MCU last year the
announcement of a successor was
therefore only a question of time s the
Hollywood Reporter reports a
screenwriter has apparently been found
namely Megan McDonald McDonald is
currently part of the writing team of
the MCU serious one division but has not
made a major movie yet if the current
negotiations between her and Marvel are
successful the script of Captain Marvel
2 will be written by one author instead
of five and there will also be female
power on the director's chair
but this search for a suitable director
is still ongoing information about the
content is not known at the moment
however the Hollywood report is sure
that the plot will take place in the
present of the MCU which is only a few
years ahead of ours moreover there is a
high chance that in part two the Captain
Marvel comics will be used in which the
main actress brie Larson in a role as
Carol Danvers aka Captain Marvel takes
command of the space station Alpha
Flight whether there will also be a
reunion with for example the Skrulls is
not known at this time according to The
Hollywood Reporter kept Marvel is
supposed to be in the cinemas in 2022
regardless that Disney has announced
three dates for still unspecified
projects mid-february late July and
early October 2022 so it's likely that
Captain mother too will be released on
one of these three dates just recently
the long-awaited
bad boys for life was released in the
cinemas as The Hollywood Reporter
reports the powerful cinema release has
now cost the Sony Studios to confirm bad
toys for which has already been hinted
at in the past a reunion of Will Smith
and Martin Lawrence should therefore
only be a matter of time under which
direction the fourth bad boys part will
be produced is not yet known but since
the performance of directors are dllr B
and Balala has been positively received
by critics a return of the two directors
is not unlikely after the first two pods
of bad boys from 1995 and bad boys two
from two
and three the third part of the series
took quite a long time the reason for
this was among other things various
disagreements with the directors and
script writers which almost led to the
third part to be cancelled at all in
2015 however the solemn announcement was
made that there would be two more
successes when the fourth part will be
released in the cinemas has not been
announced yet
however a release before the end of 2021
seems unrealistic The Witcher series on
Netflix has been a huge success so far
in addition to the already announced
second season an animated film called
The Witcher nightmare of the wolf is now
to be released as Netflix officially
announced in a recent interview with IGN
Poland The Witcher producer Tom Beck
Baginski also hinted that such a movie
might be released between the seasons it
is not yet known what role the current
cast of the series will play but the
participation of some cast members as
dubbing actors is quite likely given the
high recognition value the idea for the
film is said to have come from bode Mayo
showrunner Lauren history who had known
about it for over a year was now pleased
to finally officially treat the fans
according to her own statement the film
should expand the world of The Witcher
and tell about a powerful new danger on
the witcher continent nothing more
precise is known above the release date
but since season 2 is supposed to be
released in 2021
a release at the end of 2020 or the
beginning of 2021 would be quite
realistic the last Indiana Jones movie
was released 12 years ago for almost as
long they have been speculations about
the sequel Indiana Jones 5 until now the
film has been postponed again and again
for various reasons either due to the
script or because the people in charge
preferred to devote themselves to other
projects the release currently planned
by Disney is in July 2021 but will
everything really work out this time
David Koepp who left the project at some
point is now responsible for the content
as a screenwriter again according to his
own statement this scriptwriter of
Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull has got a really good idea
for the script
director Steven Spielberg who currently
has little time away from his post
production project West Side Story will
then take on the film in the course of
the year another important person of
course is the 77 year old leading actor
Harrison Ford who after the release of
his last film the call of the wild on
February 21st 2020 will have great
enthusiasm to once again embody his cult
role of Indiana Jones so what else could
the plant release in the next summer
fail for one thing screenwriter cap must
first complete the scripts with his good
idea and then convince Disney director
Spielberg and actor Harrison fought with
it so if the script is right there's
nothing to stop the release Indiana
Jones 5 is scheduled to be released on
July 9th 2021 with national treasure and
national treasure Book of Secrets Disney
deliver 2 very good adventure films in
mm which with a total of around 800
million US dollars in box office takings
were above all very profitable the
release of the second part is 12 years
ago and fans probably did not expect a
sequel so soon in 2019 Disney boss Bob
Iger stated that they were not 100%
satisfied with the scripts but this
could now belong to the past because as
reported by The Hollywood Reporter and
variety Chris Brander is currently
working on the script for national
treasure three Bremner is considered a
rising newcomer in Hollywood and his
script for bad boys for life was a
complete success at the moment no
information is available on the release
date of national treasure 3 but
considering the current production
progress we will probably have to wait
until at least 2020 3 a few months ago
JJ Abrams production company bad robots
made a million-dollar deal with Warner a
few days ago the magazine deadline
reported that bad robots allegedly
develops movies in series based on
Justice League dark it is not yet known
what specific plans bad robots has in
this regard
also if Abrams will direct the projects
himself or if he will give the direction
to someone else is still not certain
nevertheless it seems to be planned that
the Justice League dark will be really
in the cinema as well as on the new
Warner streaming service HBO max it is
also questionable whether the films and
serious will then be integrated into the
DC EU or the new DC series multiverse or
whether they will stand completely on
their own the ladder is rather unlikely
as it would make more sense to link the
existing Justice League dark formats
with each other with the current state
of information it is still difficult to
estimate when and in what form the
projects will be released so we hope to
get more information about Justice
League dark in the near future tyka
white titi is best known for his film
thor ragnarok
and most recently with a six-time
oscar-nominated film jojo rabbit he also
directed one episode of the mandalorian
and lent his voice to the robots IG 11
The Hollywood Reporter is now
speculating that YTD could also become a
Star Wars director in the future at
least that would be an exciting
consideration after all the directors
known for his humor and plot twists if
this is just a dream or if he will
actually direct a new Star Wars movie is
not clear at the moment one factor that
speaks against this is surely his busy
schedule at the moment ytt is still in
post-production for his new movie next
goal wins and will dedicate himself to
four love and thunder afterwards after
filming for the question is whether he
will take over a sequel to Akira as
already hinted at or starred at a
completely new project this new project
could be Star Wars however that's just
speculation at the moment many many fans
would like to see the x-men in a bigger
role in the MCU after the Fox takeover
last year this is now possible at least
on paper because all the characters of
the x-men are in the possession of
Marvel again when the five-year plan of
Marvel was presented the disappointment
was big at first because the superheroes
unfortunately don't play a role in it at
least for the time being
since Marvel boss Kevin Feige announced
that the x-men will play a role in the
MCU but that we will have to be patient
as Professor X actor Patrick Stewart
recently stated in an interview with
Digital Spy they were supposed to have
been a conversation between him and
foggy also the character Charles XA
aka Professor X is rumored to have been
discussed however it was Stewart himself
who spoke out against the return of his
character because his performance in the
2017 film Logan the Wolverine changed
everything he said here's the problem if
we had not made Logan then yes I would
probably be ready to get into that
wheelchair one more time and be Charles
Xavier but Logan changed all that so
Stewart is unfortunately no longer
available for the role of Professor X
currently this 79 year old Stewart can
be seen on Amazon in the Sirius Star
Trek pika
[Music]